you got to make sure that whatever
you're doing is a great product or
service it has to be really great if
you're a new company I mean this is like
some new industry or new market that if
it's an untapped market or then the
standard is lower for your product or
service but if you're entering anything
where there's an existing market place
against lodge and trenched competitors
then your product or service needs to be
much better than theirs it can't be a
little bit better because then you put
yourself in the shoes of the consumer
and they say why would you buy it or
he's gonna buy the trusted brand unless
there's a big difference so a lot of
times you know entrepreneur will come up
with something which is only slightly
better and it's it's not you can't just
be slightly better it's got to be a lot
better depending on how well you want to
do and particularly if you're starting a
company you need to work super hard so
what is super heart mean well when my
brother and I was starting out first
company instead of getting an apartment
we just rented us a small office and we
slept on the couch and we showered at
the YMCA and we're so hot up we had one
computer so the the website was up
during the day and I was coding at night
seven days a week all the time and I
sort of briefly had a gopher in that
period and in order to deal with me she
had to sleep in the office so I work
hard like it you mean every waking hour
that's that's the the thing I would I
would say if you're particularly if
you're starting a company and I mean if
you do simple math to say like okay if
somebody else is working 50 hours and
you're working 100 you'll get twice as
done as much done in the course of a
year as the other company you just watch
- amazing clip some Elon Musk
take the next three minutes to sit
quietly and think about how to apply
them to your business and your life
believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]